Oh nipples, without you chests would be pointless.
Hello everyone, Julian here for DNews.
Nipples: everybody has them, but you probably
don’t pay them much attention.
That is unless you’re cold, aroused, or
talking about science and your little bosom
buddies decide to stand at attention for all
the world to see.
How do nipples get hard, and what purpose
does this serve?
Answering the how is a bit easier than answering
the why, especially thanks to a recent study
published in Nature Neuroscience.
Researchers were interested in the sympathetic
nervous system, which is most known for its
role in the fight or flight response.
If you’re not familiar with it, of course
we’ve covered it, and you can check out
that video to learn about it in-depth.
But back to the researchers -- When they were
examining the sympathetic nervous system in
mice, the researchers found that it was more
specialized to respond to specific stimuli
than previously assumed.
The scientists followed nerves in the system
from where they originated in the spinal cord
to where they connect to other structures
like the blood vessels, muscles, and yes,
nipples.
They found there were 8 distinct types of
neurons wired to specific areas, each expressing
different genes and responding to different
stimuli.
So there is actually a type of neuron that
exists just to make your nipples erect.
When these neurons are activated by the neurotransmitter
norepinephrine, they cause erector muscles
to contract, tightening your areola and causing
your milk duds to harden.
Titillating as this information is, it still
doesn’t answer why nipples need to get hard
in the first place.
What’s the point of the point?
The most obvious reason is for breast feeding.
A baby’s suckling reflex is activated when
something strokes the roof of their mouth,
so a stiff nipple will help get the little
sucker to latch on for a meal.
But what about when it’s time to make a
baby, or when it’s cold, or when nipples
go rogue and pitch a shirt-tent for no obvious
reason?
Science is a little more perplexed about that.
It’s possible that hard nipples are supposed
to serve as a signal of arousal, but it’s
a pretty terrible signal if it also shows
up just because it’s cold.
That’s like having a thermometer where all
the numbers are replaced with winking emojis,
it tells you nothing!
It’s possible we get nipply when it’s
nippy because the muscles in our areolas and
under our hair follicles respond to the same
stimuli.4 The scientists who discovered what
I will heretofore call the “nipple neuron”
found another kind of neuron that also responds
to norepinephrine and causes your hair to
stand on end4.
This might be a vestigial trait from when
we were more hirsute, and our hair puffed
out to trap air and keep us warmer.
It’s also frequently suggested our hair
rises in stressful situations in an effort
to make us look bigger.
You can imagine how puffed out hair would
be helpful when you’re being attacked by
a predator, though it’s a little harder
to see how stiff nips will intimidate a bear.
Maybe it’ll think you’re aroused and be
kind of weirded out.
If the only surefire reason nipples get stiff
is to help with breastfeeding, then why do
men even have nipples?
It’s a classic question, and it’s one
that deserves a classic episode, so I’ll
let Laci Green explain it here.
The human body is totally fascinating and
awesome and if there are any weird bodily
phenomenons you’d like us to explain, tell
us!
You can let us know in the comments, subscribe
for more and I'll see you guys next time on
DNews.